So, uh, welcome to this the, uh,
unprompted scone basement version. Um,
sorry if the screens are a little bit
small. You should be able to see
everything. Uh, so yeah, thanks for
having us. Uh, we're really excited to
be here at first unprompted con. A lot
of familiar faces and people doing AI
security now who've been doing security
forever.
So, it's probably not shocking to this
room, but AI can find vulnerabilities
now, and it's getting pretty good. Um,
there's, you know, another track just
right up here, uh, covering the same
subject. Um, and for many of us who have
been paying attention to this space, uh,
or testing this kind of capability,
right, it's been getting better and
better for almost a year at this point.
um you know both internal uh internal
research as well as academic papers you
know trusted researchers and everybody
have been saying this as well and
without talking about you know specific
vendors or specific startups there's a
lot of potential open- source solutions
from you know more robust projects to
you know what I'm now calling
slopkitties
uh and you know it's no longer just
startups right there's you know
solutions from anthropic there are
solutions from open AI um these voling
systems you know Big sleep was mentioned
this morning have been uh making good
progress within these companies as well
as now offering those solutions to open
source.
So LMS can find vaults but we really
wondered you know about 6 months ago can
I also inject vaults? Enter project
marinade.
So, as we say in security, right, PC or,
you know, get the [\h__\h] out, eval
critical. And, you know, you heard this
a bunch already today, evals, evals,
evals. And really thought, you know,
hey, this ability to use LLM agents to,
you know, write code or find
vulnerabilities, you know, could we
inject them synthetically into into a
codebase of a given project uh and then
either test on finding those bones or uh
test other products that we already have
with some ground truth.
And you of course can inject to almost
any kind of code, right? It doesn't it
can be Python, it can be C, it can be an
internal project, it can be a third
party project that you're worried about.
Um, and you know, you can make these
vulnerabilities very surface level and
easy to find, or you can make them
harder to find.
And so, you know, as a company or a
researcher, you know, you might want to,
if you're evaluating a certain product
or a new solution that's fancy, right,
you might want to say, hey, does this
find vulnerabilities in my codebase? Is
it reliable? Is it cheaper? Is it
faster? What's the signal to noise ratio
for what I know are ground truth
vulnerabilities now in this codebase?
And you can rewind and try older
historical, you know, commits or
something like that, but that only works
for a certain amount of things or you
may only have a certain amount of code
that has that.
So, let's back up a second. So, I'm I'm
Erin. This is Skyler. We both work at
Nvidia.
And I want to be clear, too. This is
building on the shoulders of giants,
right? AIC did a lot of work injecting
synthetic vulnerabilities into code
bases and part of their their um cyber
challenge, cyber reasoning challenge
that you know finished um uh this last
year at DevCon. Um and I don't know if
they did that by hand, but we thought,
hey, maybe we can be lazy. So about 6
months ago, right, AI coding agents are
getting a lot better. They're getting
able to reason about code and reason
about large amounts of code. So we
figured, hey, maybe we could just say
insert a few vulnerabilities and it just
would work, right? We just get cloud
code or we get cursor or get agent uh
thing of the week and you know GPUs to
the rescue. But you know in sort of a
record scratch sound the latest models
actually will refuse this quite a bit.
Uh and you know cyber is dual use right
I get that that's a hard problem to
solve. um you know the the OpenAI's
trusted access is actually like a good
move in this direction and letting
researchers be able to um have a bit
less refusals to do you know defensive
security verge or or approved defensive
security verge. Uh and so that's
certainly uh you know a good development
but we also you'll see that this isn't
something that will work. You can't just
say hey in search of vulnerability you
know be better. uh it'll you know it it
here you know it's adding a very very
simplistic vulnerability which is you
know classic string overflow in a you
know configuration file parsing which is
not really a realistic risk if you can
reload a configuration file usually you
already have control of of that machine
or that service or whatever it would be.
So you know even with state-of-the-art
models uh it didn't really go so well.
So we wrote a bunch of instructions
right that said hey how to do this what
are the attack surfaces how do you
consider uh you know what kind of of
historical vulnerabilities would be
common in this codebase or with this
programming language or you know maybe
do some research about open CVEes for
this uh and you know these instructions
or I mean sorry skills these these
skills can call other skills um and you
know these skills end up using as kind
of working as their own form of a
jailbreak. So, if you have a have a
defined set of skills and you say, "Hey,
go use these skills." Um, instead of
putting your prompt, you know, right in
the the thing, they'll go ahead and and
um they'll follow that and it works
pretty well.
So, we have these skills, uh, they can
call tools. It it's saving us a lot of
time. And it seems a little bit silly in
some ways to write down your, you know,
your process or whatever it could be
into just some markdown files. Um, but
honestly, it works pretty well. and
English is, you know, the new coding
language.
What's also cool about these
state-of-the-art skills and
state-of-the-art coding agents is that
they can ask questions, right? You can
have a human in the loop and say, "Ah,
yeah, you that vulnerability is not
quite that realistic." Or, you know, I
really want you to change how the
difficulty of this is really easy for a
scanner to find. I want it to be hard
for a scanner to find to really make
sure I'm measuring things correctly.
But the general idea right is similar to
the progress that you similar to the
process that you might follow right
review the application review the code
base come up with some way to build it
make sure that it works um then go and
look at what the programming language is
what kind of typical vulnerabilities are
common in that uh kind of programming or
is this a client server architecture or
is this a you know SQL engine or
whatever it could be and then of course
like you create plans for those things
you follow that process and you go from
there. Then we often will have the skill
uh one of the skills is you know
creating a diff uh for each change that
you make creating a branch for all the
modifications and documentation that the
coding agent will add to this process.
So you can go back to potentially you
know like the middle of the process.
Uh and then of course each vulnerability
because we can't just believe that these
things are are going to work or it'll
end up reward hacking. uh you want to
have some kind of verification
and this process will iterate and loop
and you can go from there and at the end
of course you have documentation and a
report of all the things that were
changed and why they were changed and
unless you go back and change uh you
know if you want to modify something but
of course you know uh you can't really
prompt yourself to perfection and so
there are problems with this kind of
architecture even if we uh you know have
spent some time on it right models have
bias there's a lot of lack of ingenuity.
Um you know there's old information and
training data related things that the
models will try to introduce. You saw in
that earlier example right even with
like you know opus 46 or something it'll
just say oh you know stir copy you're
we're done right it's no no um and you
know they will sometimes refuse even
with the skills when it you get to
certain types of vulnerabilities or
certain types of uh you know proof of
concept exploitation and things like
that. Um, so some of the solutions for
those are somewhat obvious, right?
Somewhat better prompting, somewhat ways
of trying to ground things to reality.
Um, and uh, you'll also, uh, find some
success in swapping models around. So
you might get stuck with one model,
switch to a different one, and then kind
of you can switch back and say, "Hey,
can continue on with this." And it'll
just keep going. Um, reward hacking will
also be a problem. Right? Here's an
example where in an earlier version
where um it introduced an XFCE
vulnerability by just disabling the XSSE
protection like that's not not exactly
what we meant. Um and of course you know
similar uh recommendations for this kind
of thing right better better models
better planning um and you know in some
cases human verification but that that
will slow things down. Um, another thing
you'll often run into is like maybe your
code has to be compiled in order to test
things or maybe it needs to run in a
Docker container to make it easy to
portable. Um, the models, you know, even
6 months ago would have potentially had
problems with this or got lost or forget
to compile once they made changes. Um,
and so this is something that that you
might run into. However, you know, the
latest models are really getting a lot
better here. Um, sub agents will speed
some things up a lot. you can do things
in parallel and then you know better
planning uh better setup generally uh
will save you. You'll also sometimes
find problems with applications that
need some kind of setup, right? Maybe it
needs to be um you know, you can modify
the codebase, but then you need to click
through a bunch of configuration steps
or you need configuration files need to
be generated. The good thing is, you
know, AI can just generate all that for
us or you can use things like playright
to automate, you know, browser clicking
if you have to kind of go down that
path.
Um, you'll also run into, you know, if
you're just creating Python scripts for
replicating vulnerabilities or something
in some cases, especially on the
website, you'll run into cases where,
you know, there's a CRSF token that
needs to get refreshed for every single
time. Um, or there's different
authorization you need to handle and the
model has to keep track of all that. But
again, that's something that you can um,
you know, document your way into
improving um, or use things like
playright browser automation.
Um and then you know one of the core
things is just where the decision wise
of things right so you know should you
expose some vulnerable attack surface
that's already in the app because again
for a lot of this we don't want to be
modifying the app to introduce
vulnerable behavior we just want to
tweak like the smallest amount of code
uh to keep things as as uh as uh similar
to the like real app as possible right
um or should you do things like maybe we
will uh you know modify the surface
level code so it's easy to mind instead
of modifying some really deep down hard
to find thing if you're going to be
evaluating um you know just a scanner
versus like a you know a human or a
pentest team or whatever you have um and
the nice thing is you know with AI you
can just do both or you can make two or
you can make three right just like the
the OpenAI you know presentation earlier
this morning like you can just do things
so in general from from some of the you
know solutions that make things better
right um you cannot just prompt a few
times with cloud code and just get a
good result here you really need the
structure, you need various skills to go
through and be able to do these things.
Um, you will also need to use the latest
and greatest models just because, you
know, as we know, right, they're getting
better. You'll get better results. Um,
and, um, yeah, swapping around models or
using, you know, using codecs to do one
thing and then creating it again and
using, you know, Opus 46 to do another
one, um, you'll get some some results.
But I'll hand it over to to Skyler now.
>> Thank you. Um, so I'm going to go over
some of the results that we ran into. A
lot of it is just artifacts that are
created by this process that inform the
agent on how to move forward. Um, we've
had good success with a number of
different uh application architectures,
programming languages, um, internal
apps, um, as well as obviously open
source apps. Those are what we spend
most of our time on here.
Um so one of the first things that we
ended up doing is kind of uh on this
kind of reiteration was was creating
modes that helped us address specific
use cases, right? Um so obviously
there's an interactive mode that's like
your human in the loop approach um where
you get to direct it and to uh approve
every single v uh vulnerability that's
planned and its approach uh on how it's
imple implemented. Um, next you have
like an OASP top 10 where it just takes
an app and it tries to create a
vulnerability from each one of these
classes. Um, and this is basically a way
to make your own web goat if you're
familiar with that project. Um, so
that's handy for training, but obviously
it's just um also handy for evaluations.
Um, CWES, if you if you know the
specific types of vulnerability classes
that you want to target, um, give it the
C.WE we and it will find an appropriate
spot in that codebase um to inject a
vulnerability of that class. And if you
want to get more specific, you can give
it a CVE and say emulate this specific
vulnerability implementation
um and it will go and find provided it
is available source code will go and
find it and emulate the structure of
that as closely as it can within the
target application.
And finally, we have a auto rce, which
is just a way for us to say build a
bunch of different vulnerabilities that
independently aren't very useful, but
can be chained together to ultimately
achieve remote code execution.
We also support like a number uh you can
specify the difficulty level uh easy,
medium, hard. Easy like Aaron mentioned
is something that we don't care if it
gets caught by a scanner. Um medium we
don't want to be caught by a scanner.
Um, so if we do get caught, we'll
reiterate over that loop until we can
get it passed and hard. We try and make
it difficult for humans to be able to
reason about um using a various
techniques that make it really hard to
find these things.
All right, so next we have our build
process that kind of what kicks off once
we've defined our configuration, we kick
off the build and we produce some
artifacts here that are useful for the
rest of the process. we create and I
know this is really hard to read um but
on the side you see some scripts that
are used to start and stop our
application to run our build tests um so
we run our build tests initially to make
sure that the build is sound um and that
we're working with a good application
and we use that test later after each
vulnerability injection to confirm that
the functionality uh is is not broken
somehow
and then on the on in the middle you can
see the document that it prepares that
describes the build process in detail.
Um it'll refer back to this as it needs
to rebuild after each injection.
All right. Finally, uh nope. Um so after
we've completed the build process,
actually these can be run in parallel.
Um the next process is analysis where we
we deep dive into the application try to
understand everything we can about it um
to make it easier to to inject realistic
vulnerabilities.
Um you can see here or maybe you can't
but I'll describe it. The um executive
summary kind of just describes the main
components. It goes through all of the
plan vulnerabilities
um and describes some potential entry
points to inject that vulnerability.
Then it goes um through and it
identifies all of the the technology
stack which components are being used,
which libraries uh which versions. It
also tries to group functionality into
um different categories. So if it's
trying to find place to inject a
specific vulnerability, it can use these
categories to identify code that might
be susceptible to those types of
vulnerabilities.
Uh additionally, it goes through all of
the architectural
I feel like we just covered that one. Um
so then it also describes like the main
components and this will change
obviously on your architecture. Um but
it it lays it out describing each one
how it works. um enumerates all the the
end points um and
data flow patterns. So it'll try it and
say all right here's how this workflow
works uh when you're trying to fill a
database or uh browse keys in in the
database. Um so you can have so the
agent has this information as it's going
through trying to find the best place to
inject these
uh more security related. So it
basically looks for specific security
implementation details, authentication,
authorization, cryptography, all the
different security mechanisms that are
present in the application tries to
identify them um and enumerate.
And finally we have like actually not
finally but we have some
ex uh external integrations. So these
are where we our app integrates
elsewhere which is a fun place to inject
vulnerabilities
and then we do a baseline scan. So
before we start injecting any
vulnerabilities do a baseline scan to
understand what is actually there. Um so
that we can compare after we inject our
vulnerability to make sure it's not
detected.
Okay. After that we we build a bunch of
functional tests. So we understand the
app, we understand the architecture, the
components, uh we understand
functionality. We're the common
workflows and we build functional tests
um to test this uh dynamically so that
we can get confidence that after we
inject something we're not breaking
existing functionality
and there's a just specific uh
functionality is documented um key paths
to specific source files that might be
interesting. It also does like an
architecture diagram.
It's really not that great at it yet.
Um, but if you look at it, it's it's
actually fairly accurate. And these are
created in mermaids. So, it has a
textual representation that it can use
to understand relationships between
various components without trying to
understand this diagram.
And then finally, we're ready to inject
some flaws. Right? We we've done our
analysis. We have ideas of what we want
to inject. how difficult it should be
and where we want to try injecting
these. Um you can see here we have a
plan to create a chained uh
vulnerability that ends up in rce.
This is an example of one of the
prompts. This is specifically a
vulnerability injection prompt which
gives guidance on how to do it, how to
make it realistic um and gives
guidelines around
our our idea of realistic like not
touching the tests uh unit test for
example um to hide our injected
vulnerability.
And once we
inject the vulnerability,
sorry, we um
we document or so we we this is part of
the planning phase. Sorry, I kind of
skipped over it, but you'll notice here
like we ask for a top 10. It says no,
only eight of those categories make
sense for this application. I'm only
going to move forward and try and inject
these eight. the other would be
unrealistic or would require adding
additional functionality that wasn't
already present. Now obviously it can
add additional tac surface um but in
this case we don't want it to we wanted
to use the existing functionality
and then once it's defined the
implementation it can do additional
things like generate sequence diagrams
to describe that vulnerability in detail
so that human can understand exactly how
it works once it's injected.
And obviously injecting these
vulnerabilities uh is great but we we
need to know that this is not a false
positive. So we need to validate that
that exploit sorry that vulnerability is
exploitable. Um so we generate
validation scripts that will do that. We
have a critique, sorry, a critic that
will critique a vulnerability plan as
well as an implementation
um to make sure that it's aligned with
what we're looking for and reward sorry
avoid kind of reward hacking.
Um and once we've done all this, we've
we've confirmed that the injections are
validated, they work properly, we run a
vulnerability scan again to identify
what we missed or sorry, what it missed.
Um, and at this point, like I said, if
we were setting it to hard or medium, it
might have to go back and try again
using some of the information about how
it was caught to do additional evations.
All right,
cool. So, let's talk about where else
the can go. So, obviously this works on
source code, but of course you can also
take it further and have compiled
binaries. So you could take your source
code, introduce vulnerabilities, compile
those binaries, and then test about, you
know, patch diff analysis or end days or
whatever you're worried about, right?
You could test that in this situation as
well. You can also marinate more than
just source code, right? You could
inject into configuration files if you
have some kind of security process
that's checking those. You could insert
into log files if you want to check for
uh, you know, some detection thing to
fire, right? You don't actually
necessarily even have to do a red team.
you could just synthetically generate
one uh and then test your system or test
your sock or whatever it could be. So
that's pretty cool. And then with a lot
of this, right, you enter a world where
you have more verifiable rewards and so
you could potentially generate a whole
bunch of synthetic training data from a
corpus like this and then make a better
model so on and so forth. Um you know
this system uh as we've been using it is
certainly not perfect, right? There are
lots of times where it will reward hack
or where we'll have to go back and be
more in the loop on a certain type of
vulnerability that you want. Um, and so
obviously, you know, it's getting
better. We're playing around with also
like having layers of reviewers or
critics or things like that in order to
to get things better. Um, being able to
kick off some kind of deep research as
part of an agent would be pretty cool.
Um, and so on. And you know, I think we
want to end on just this fact that like
right now, right, we're we're not in
cyber Kansas anymore, right? It's very
interesting times for the security
industry, for the AI industry. Um, and
uh, you know, there's a lot of exciting
stuff happening and and yeah, go build
things.
>> I think we have a couple minutes for
questions.
>> Absolutely. Uh, put your hand up if you
got a question. We're right here.
Hey, uh I know you mentioned uh about
using the newer models because the
capabilities are better, but do you
think that the problem you were running
into earlier around won't generate
vulnerable code like that'll start to
catch up on the skills and other newer
>> Yeah, definitely that's a good concern.
And I think that's hope where hope like
maybe some of the like OpenAI trusted
access right where certain companies can
get like you know if if you you know get
can get potentially approved to have
some of the things turned down right or
like classifiers or whatever so you
don't get an angry email uh and things
but yeah it'll always be a race of of
being able to do that. That's a good
question though. Thanks.
>> Hey thanks. uh you talked about realism
during the evaluations. How central to
uh the evaluation metrics are realism
and anecdotally where on the sliding
scale of CTF challenge to like real
vulnerabilities do you think the phones
wound up landing?
>> Yeah, that's a really good question. So
uh I do I do think you know uh you could
do a whole talk I think on why we need
to go away from CTF style evaluations
and things and like getting away from
you know damn vulnerable Linux and juice
job and all these things right. So uh we
focused a lot on trying to make it as
real as possible. I think the problem is
yeah we have our own bias about like
what's real or you know whatever. I
think that's where some of the modes
come into play of like if you had maybe
you know we know programmers make
similar mistakes again and again or
companies or frameworks right so you
might be able to have a system where you
um say like hey here's the last like
four vulnerabilities in this product
make a make a fifth one that's very
similar to these right so it it's
certainly like it's something we've been
playing with u but it's it's not super
easy cuz you know LLM's only know so
much
>> yeah thanks
>> I guess the next question is from me
which is related to that like companies
write a lot of the same software over
and over and over again. Do you find
over time you guys spend more time
dealing with separate prompts, separate
context on anti-reward hacking, making
sure it's not just saying, "Hey, I did a
great job."
>> It's gotten a lot better. Like 6 months
ago, you had to babysit and be like
human in the loop a lot. Um now,
especially for, you know, like certain
types of code bases or certain types of
problems you're introducing, um it'll
you know, it can really go on its own.
Um, the one where it still sometimes
will do nonsensical stuff, especially
like the the like chaining vulnerability
chaining. You're like, this is this I
would not exploit this and then exploit
that. Like that doesn't really make
sense. Um, but some of the other more
like simple modes are pretty pretty
reliable. Yeah,
>> I think we can probably take one more.
>> Okay. Uh, it seems like you've built the
perfect tool for inserting back doors
into existing code bases through
malicious pull requests. Have you tried
leveraging this in an offensive
capacity? No comment.
Thanks a lot, guys.